how's it going everybody it's Warren
today we have some major news about
everybody's favorite god of mischief
Loki as if everybody wasn't already
excited enough about the Loki series the
one division series and Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness it appears
that all three of the MCS greatest
sorcerers are going to be in one film so
let's break down what Kevin Feige has
recently said in an interview confirming
that Loki will tie directly into the
multiverse of madness I'm still giving
away an Xbox one or ps4 so be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment down below to enter
Disney Plus is only a week away from
launching everybody is super excited and
today during an interview with Bloomberg
and Disney CEO Bob Iger and Kevin Feige
and during this interview Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios was
asked if the Loki series will tie in to
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and Kevin Feige very
nonchalantly answered I'm not sure we've
actually acknowledged that before but it
does so we have official confirmation
from the president of Marvel Studios
that Loki is going to be in Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness and
this is extremely exciting news but it
doesn't really come as that much of a
surprise Avengers in game essentially
created different realities and
alternate universes and although the
Avengers were very careful and very
cautious of not creating alternate
realities they did and not just one but
a few one of course was created when the
Avengers went back in time to the events
of the first Avengers film and Loki
escaped with the tesseract this of
course created an alternate timeline one
that dr. strange is most likely going to
have to deal with in the multiverse of
madness this could perhaps be the way
that Loki returns to the main MCU
timeline because what is really
interesting is that Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness comes out
before the Loki series comes out so that
means that Doctor Strange is definitely
going to be dealing with what the
alternate universe is after all it is in
the title the multiverse of madness this
means that we're going to see Loki in
the MCU before the Loki series Doctor
Strange will most likely go out and try
to fix the alternate timelines that were
created and during that process of
course he's going to stumble upon the
timeline that Loki created now Loki is
extremely smart he's the god of
and he will most likely catch on to what
is happening he will probably realize
that time travel was involved and he'll
most likely realized that he created an
alternate reality and perhaps he'll take
this opportunity of dr. strange going to
his reality as a chance to return to the
main MCU timeline or perhaps he'll try
to stay in the new timeline and try to
be the ruler of the one that has been
created because remember this is Loki
from 2012 he's not a mature Loki he's
not necessarily good yet he hasn't been
through all of the events that have kind
of turned his heart around so he's not
exactly going to be an ally to dr.
strange but we know that Loki somehow
has to return to the main timeline
because he's going to be in Thor love
and thunder it's been reported that Loki
is going to be the one that brings mule
near back to the main MCU timeline which
then of course Jane Foster's go into
Weald when she becomes lady Thor so Loki
has to get back somehow or at least find
a way to travel between different
realities and it looks like he may
figure out a way how to do this in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness either way the god of mischief
is returning in the multiverse of
madness and Doctor Strange and the
Scarlet Witch are going to have to
figure out a way to deal with him
how do you think it'll happen let me
know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below and also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on the
MCU and so you can enter for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll fluff